if you want to know more about jigsaw's
backstory like the details only included
in the comic and if you want to see the
full chronology of what i think is the
only accurate timeline of the events of
john kramer's life on the internet
then stick around to the end of this
video
many of my favorite horror villains are
not monsters in the typical sense of
having a scary appearance or
intimidating demeanor but instead
project more of a psychological [ __ ]
oftentimes brought on by a distorted
sense of how they see the world many of
the best antagonists or anti-heroes are
scary to me because they actually
believe that they're doing the world of
service with their misdeeds and the
agent of the events that we've come to
know is the saw franchise is a model
example of this chilling behavior
welcome to horror history my name is
very [ __ ] confused
my name is very [ __ ] confused what's
your name and in today's lesson i'll be
analyzing the man responsible for years
of city-wide panic a slew of
impersonators a cult of nefarious
followers a massive federal
investigation and most significantly the
deaths of at least 57 victims
i am of course referring to the jigsaw
killer john kramer most commonly known
by the nickname
jigsaw which was originally derived from
his practice of cutting jigsaw pieces
from the flesh of his failed victims as
a symbol for the missing piece of their
survival instinct
in this video we're gonna look at
jigsaw's entire life and put together
those pieces and as with any puzzle the
best way to start is by figuring out the
adjacent pieces the corner pieces such
as
john kramer's past we'll also explore
the mysteries of his background the
development of his psychopathy the
imposition of a god complex with the
religious parallels in his work and
finally the realization
of his ultimate failure so in order to
understand how the puzzle that is john
kramer was built
let's take it all the way back to his
birth
john kramer was born in the year 1954 a
fact we're able to derive from the
mention of his age at the time of death
subject's name is john kramer a 52 year
old
male caucasian so he was only in his
early 50s during the saw movies yikes
with the capital yikes like the whole
thing is capital
john's work consisted of a company he
founded called the urban renewal group
but despite how it sounds this had
nothing to do with mid 2000's hip-hop
jon was a civil engineer who worked
alongside a lawyer named art blank to
build homes for low-income families and
also sometimes created other buildings
with the intent of helping people
jon was extremely intelligent making him
a world-class engineer but he was also
great at understanding people and
anticipating their actions which made
him quite successful on the business end
as well
he was quickly able to scale urban
renewal group to the point that he owned
several buildings throughout the city
and he had a fair amount of resources
which he channeled back into helping the
people of that city
the desire to help and improve people's
lives was the first key moments to
understand his motivation because it was
this that drove his actions throughout
his entire life i would also speculate
that it was the reason he fell in love
with the woman that would become his
wife
jill tuck the doctor who ran a recovery
center for drug addicts known as
homeward bound clinic the clinic's motto
was cherish your life a phrase that john
would also associate with his own work
john and jill's love eventually led to
marriage and plans to have a first child
like in his work jon meticulously
planned all aspects of his life and the
baby was no exception the child's name
gideon was also the name of his first
building the gideon meat packing plant
and may have drawn from the hebrew name
gedan which meant hero or judge
showing us jon's subconscious desire to
judge people for their sins
the baby's planned date of birth was in
1995 the chinese year of the pig which
was a symbol of rebirth a concept that
jon believed heavily in the name gideon
and the pig symbol would have greater
meaning later in john's story but for
now he was focused on tending to his
pregnant wife
he would wait for her to get done with
work some days and he noticed some shady
characters who are patients at the
clinic one evening he has to intervene
when a fight nearly breaks out between
two addicts named cecil adams and gus
couliard and jon had to convince cecil
to put his knife away before things got
much worse
this causes jon to wonder how effective
his wife's rehabilitation methods really
are but he still encourages her work
something he would come to regret later
down the line he also displays evidence
that he's become more jaded towards the
world when he meets an insurance mogul
named william easton who sponsors a
party at jill's clinic they seem to
connect over their mutual need to
predict human behavior in their
respective jobs but john disagrees with
william's methods of trying to screen
people and determine their probability
of illness before giving them insurance
coverage you're not taking into
consideration the most important human
element of all
which is what the will to live this
exchange would be another important
puzzle piece in crafting the jigsaw
persona because john believed that he
was giving each of his victims a chance
to survive by putting them through
adversity as gideon's due date got
closer though jon continued to prepare
for the birth of his son by constructing
a crib a children's toy that resembled
the ventriloquist doll which he would
name
billy the puppet and by creating a home
video for the boy during an ultrasound
monitoring again we can pull a couple
puzzle pieces from john's preparation to
be a father
the messages he meant to save for his
son were to be passed via videotape and
he would eventually use this medium to
speak to his test subjects while the
puppet would be reimagined as the face
of jigsaw an avatar that appeared in
some of the tapes who would sometimes
make physical appearances to carry on
messages to his victims
no that's not creepy at all
unfortunately before jon ever got to
meet his son gideon
tragedy would strike on one fateful
night
one evening in late 1994 john warms up
the car while his pregnant wife closes
up the clinic and notices a distressed
cecil adams burst out of the building he
immediately knows something is wrong and
goes in to find jill collapsed on the
floor after having been hit by the
swinging door when cecil had broken in
jill was seven months pregnant at this
point so fearing for the baby's safety
he rushes her to a hospital
jon suffers a long evening of emotional
suffering and jill is shell-shocked
after doctors are unable to save the
baby
this is the beginning of john's descent
his downward spiral
if you will into becoming a psychopath
the most common characteristic of a
psycho is lack of empathy for their
victims or remorse for their actions and
we see the very beginning of this
right after the loss of gideon when jon
changes his attitude towards the drug
addicts that he previously encouraged
the idea of helping
all i wanted to do was help them
you can't help them
they have to help themselves
trauma-induced psychopathy is one of the
three major ways known to develop the
condition and for john losing the sun he
had already committed so much devotion
to was the distressing catalyst that set
things into motion we see how much it
affected him by the fact that he buried
gideon and marked the spot of the
tombstone a practice not normally used
for a miscarriage
even those closest to him like his wife
and his business partner were not in
contact with him which worried them they
decided to get together to confront him
and find him sleeping in a chair at his
workshop and gideon meatpacking plans
he's very unwelcoming towards them
showing no desire to return to his
normal life
art encourages him to channel his
negative energy into their urban renewal
project where his designs would have
been used to help low-income families
but he forfeits his shares in the
company to jill and
angrily tells them to get out he had
accomplished many things at this point
in his life but none of them had been
enough to save his family from the
unpredictable crimes of a drug addict
and in his depressed mindset he forced
himself to come up with a solution to
people like cecil it was the only way he
knew how to cope with the loss
he would use the concept of they have to
help themselves in his work and in his
deranged state he figured the first
person he should give that opportunity
to
was his son's killer he tracks down
cecil during a celebration of the
chinese new year which
knowing jon was likely the planned due
date of gideon to disguise himself he
steals a pig mask remember it was the
year of the pig
i'm just glad he upgraded to something a
little bit more spooky later on because
if i saw my kidnapper wearing this
i'd probably just start losing it like
what are you gonna do force me to star
in children's daytime television
programming
actually that does sound horrifying but
another reason it makes sense for him to
use the pig mask was that the pig in the
chinese zodiac represented rebirth and
he viewed his games as a chance for
victims to be reborn as better people he
chloroformed cecil who next awakens in
john's workshop
you did this to me no you did this to
yourself
yeah come on cecil you did this it was
all you buddy
he's delusional cecil is trapped in the
knife chair jon claims it was a tool to
reclaim his life
if he can press his face through a
barrier of eight knives and press a
lever on the other side
his restraints will be released jon
thinks this is fitting because it will
make cecil's face ugly to match his
greedy soul
cecil is able to release himself from
the chair but this is not enough to
rehabilitate him he tries to attack jon
who sidesteps and sends him tumbling
into the razer wire trap in this one
he's unable to escape
john may have told himself that letting
cecil die after giving him a second
chance was a good thing that cecil was
unable to be rehabilitated and so
killing him was just another trait of a
psychopath is the need for repeated
stimulation because jon felt that he was
doing cecil a favor by putting him
through his test he soon had the desire
to help more people and began to create
more complex traps in his workshop but
jon's good intentions would not be
enough to make future traps fair or just
and before long police would recognize
kramer's actions as the work of a serial
killer
newspaper started calling him the jigsaw
killer hoping to do something about the
decline of her marriage after losing the
baby she was carrying jill decided to
try to talk to john and give him one
more chance so she goes back into the
workshop
before finding her husband she discovers
reconnaissance photos of cecil adams
cecil was believed to be missing and
jill wondered if jon had anything to do
with it
he finds her snooping around and becomes
very angry with her telling her not to
ever come back
effectively the end of their
relationship and another sign of
psychopathic behavior
impulsivity they would get divorced not
long after after jill leaves he goes
back to work on another trap the glass
coffin
this box would allow the user to be
transported out of a collapsing room and
brought to safety
john wouldn't survive long enough to use
this trap himself instead it would be
used years later by his successor but
the fact that he was working on it
way back in the 90s is a testament to
jon's intelligence and ability to
predict possible outcomes one of the
things that makes him so dangerous as a
serial killer
despite his impressive intellect his
physical condition was about to worsen
as jon was diagnosed with colon cancer
not long after the divorce
[Music]
between the divorce and the cancer
diagnosis this was two straight
tragedies for john the cancer got to him
while he was already at the lowest of
low points and as a result he decided to
end his life he decides to do this
groundhog day style by driving his car
off a cliff but miraculously he survives
the wreck as he's lying there in the
smoking mess he realizes that he wants
to live and in order to do so he must
endure a little more pain by pulling a
stake out of himself to escape
not only was this a revelation for jon
in that he got to experience firsthand
how testing his own will to live had
supposedly healed his mind and given him
a newfound appreciation for life but it
also may have inspired him to directly
create the spike trap a trap that would
be used years later and required a
victim to remove metal stakes from
herself in order to escape
and the horsepower trap where a victim
literally experiences a car crash
after walking away from his self-imposed
car wreck his faith in the
rehabilitation method he had tried on
cecil was restored and he may have
realized that the pain factor would need
to be amplified because in order for it
to work the traps would need to test
the very fabric of human nature he got
to work on some new traps as he was
treated at the angel of mercy hospital
where he ended up being unsatisfied with
the hospitality of almost everyone
working there and mark them in his mind
as future victims to be rehabilitated
the people he encountered there were
mostly just doing
their jobs but because jon was becoming
more frustrated by the tragedies of his
life he was looking too hard for victims
to punish by finding reasons that
weren't really there over the course of
the next five to seven years john began
to pay more attention to the world
around him as he continued to receive
chemotherapy for his colon cancer he
came to meet some of the other people
who he deemed unappreciative of their
lives and planned to include them in his
upcoming test game a game in his eyes
was a series of different traps
involving multiple people that was
supposed to add a social experiment
elements to his patented rehabilitation
process
okay it wasn't really patented i just
thought that word sounded good there to
be honest
he had hoped to do more than simply
spend his time testing a series of
individuals until his time on this earth
expired
instead he wanted to create a
long-lasting societal change that would
impact people long after his passing by
running his games and letting a survivor
go on to tell the tale of their trial
when news of the horrors they
experienced broke others would be less
likely to make the same mistake
out of fear of becoming the next victim
jon wanted to turn one random act of
supposed vigilante justice into an
entire movement but soon found it could
be even more than that he decided to
hold his first game as a test
and so created it and ran it in secret
at a remote location an abandoned pig
farm that was still owned by his wife's
family he thought this was the perfect
choice because it fit his idea of the
pig icon representing rebirth
some of the victims of this test game
were people in his life at the time
this first game was a bit different than
the others in that it was more about
getting the victims to admit the
mistakes of their past the later games
were more about putting the perpetrators
in physical pain which is usually
somehow symbolic of their wrongdoing
there would be five players included in
the barn game there was ryan whose
foolish actions got his friends killed
back in high school
carly a thief who caused her victim to
have an asthma attack mitch who sold a
faulty motorcycle resulting in the death
of john's nephew
anna who is john's next door neighbor
and was normally very supportive of him
while going through the chemotherapy but
who also killed her baby and blamed it
on her sleeping husband and logan nelson
a resident of the angel of mercy
hospital who accidentally switched the
labels of john's brain scan with that of
another
patient which delayed the diagnosis of a
tumor on john's brain
as a result of this he wasn't correctly
diagnosed until 2003 and by that point
it's too late the physicians working on
his case dr lawrence gordon and dr lynn
denlon were cold and unsympathetic
towards him during his treatment and
john did not like the way that dr gordon
told him how long he had to live
he planned to possibly test the two
doctors in future games but for now he
had collected enough players to run his
test game so he collected them
brought them to the tuck pig farm and
john kramer's first experiment began any
attempt
to violate my rules will kill you
i want to play a game when the game
begins jon keeps track of the progress
of each player by monitoring the rooms
with security cameras later iterations
of the games would have him physically
presence to make sure that the rules of
each
game are followed so i'm guessing that
technology was used here in the test
game because two of the contestants anna
and logan already knew who john cramer
was
hello emma
each player wakes up with a bucket on
their head and is instructed to make a
blood sacrifice but logan didn't wake up
at the same time as the others giving
him an unfair disadvantage
jon recognizes this and doesn't think it
would be right for logan to die because
of a small mistake so he stops the
spinning saw blades and bails them out
logan had suffered large lacerations
across his back but with the jon's help
he's able to have them stitched up and
he survives
from there the rest of the game plays
out as planned until there are only two
survivors remaining anna and ryan
wearing the updated version of the pig
mask jon reenters the game and once more
sedates them while they're unconscious
he moves them to another part of the
barn called to the slaughter room if
you're wondering if there's a reason
that it's called that
there is and there's about to be a
second one ryan and anna are locked to
opposite sides of the room and jon
finally reveals himself to deliver the
rules of this final challenge
now the game's simple the best ones are
you have one shotgun
you have one show he doesn't
specifically tell them that the gun is
configured backwards the theme of this
game from the beginning was for them to
find salvation by looking inwards
while i am certain that there is a
desire to point fingers at me
for the blood that has been shed unless
you turn that finger inward
i assure you more blood will be lost
the same principle ends up applying for
the gun now if you want to achieve your
freedom
you have to learn you have to realize
that
you've been doing it backwards so when
anna fails to take these clues into
consideration and tries killing ryan
with the gun she ends up shooting
herself
the key that would have released them
was also hidden in the bullet casing
left inside of the gun so it's destroyed
when anna shoots it and so are ryan's
chances of ever escaping that leaves
only one survivor of the test game logan
nelson and he would actually be the one
to give shape to the next piece of the
jigsaw puzzle
let's just go back one moment to the
point where john kramer reveals himself
in a game for the first time
when he comes out to address ryan and
anna he's wearing a new costume a hooded
robe that almost makes him look like a
monk or priest
this pig farm was no temple but the
attire does lead me to the next piece of
the jigsaw puzzle the religious aspect
of jon's teachings when i said he was
creating a movement it wasn't only about
scaring the citizens into behaving as he
wants them to based on the cautionary
tales of the survivors but he also wants
to develop his own cult his own group of
followers that would pass down his
teachings and eventually take over for
him when he was gone
in order to truly change the world he
would have to create something that
would still inspire this behavior for
future generations and the only way to
do that was for his followers to pass
down his values
[Music]
the first step to doing this is by
painting himself as a religious leader
by wearing these robes in doing so he
started to see himself as a god
as discussed in the horror history
episode on mark hoffman a god complex is
an unshakable belief characterized by
consistently inflated feelings of
personal ability
privilege or infallibility in other
words he thinks he can do no wrong the
religious attire was kind of a final
step towards jon truly believing that he
was a god and according to psychologist
and author harold kaplan's definition of
a god complex
jigsaw's behavior fits it to a t a
person with a god complex may refuse to
admit the possibility of their error or
failure
even in the face of irrefutable evidence
and intractable problems
in john's case look no further than his
previous trap with cecil adams he
believed that if cecil suffered through
the knife chair he would be instantly
rehabilitated but he wasn't he still
tried to attack jon
after escaping but even after seeing
that go down jon refuses to believe that
his methods are faulty and continues
with his plans to create new traps
i also think it's no coincidence that
cecil's surname is adams
cecil is jon's first victim to be
punished for wrongdoing and in the
biblical story of adam and eve adam is
the one to take the forbidden fruit
which gets them banned from the garden
of eden
i'm not really sure how i how to say
this but
i just have to say this so that no one
makes the same mistake i have done
i'm not sure how many of you know this
but i've actually been permanently
banned for life other indicators of a
god complex include a person highly
dogmatic in their views meaning the
person speaks of their personal opinions
as though they were unquestionably
correct
just listen to the way that john
addresses his victims in a booming
god-like voice might i add as if his
judgments of them are completely
irrefutable
you deny culpability no doubt for the
circumstances
in which you find yourselves salvation
can be yours if you cleanse yourselves
of the habitual lies
which have brought you here he even
speaks using language that you might
find in religious texts when addressing
his victims the final indicator of a god
complex is exhibiting no regard for the
conventions and demands of society they
may request
special consideration or privileges
john's methods are against the law
obviously he would soon start holding
more public-facing games but since he
views what he's doing as morally just he
disregards the rules of our society
actually i will need to remain here
while you deal with your problem
detective matthews
so john is a textbook example of someone
with a god complex but a religion cannot
work with only a god or a leader it also
requires followers and john had already
found his first one
after saving logan nelson from the barn
game he takes him under his wing and
trains him in the ways of jigsaw he
explains the basic concepts upon which
he operates many religions use some kind
of text or commandments to impress a
moral code on their followers jigsaw's
games each have rules and the ideals
expressed in these tapes serve as the
religious text the main method of john
kramer's teachings
most religious texts date back thousands
of years or more and john's teachings
gain a similar immortality when a
website is founded to spread his word
even after his death
um logan you ever heard of a website
called jigsaw rules
it's a sight devoted to jigsaw and of
course the most important part of the
cult of jigsaw and the saw franchise in
general
is the traps in religion there are
usually abstract concepts of sin leading
to punishment
popular ones include heaven and hell
while others use a system of karma and
reincarnation
john's religion kind of combines both
ideas the traps cause suffering as a
form of punishment for those who have
sinned but he views his suffering as
transformative he thinks the survivors
of his traps are reborn as better people
and that leads us back
to logan nelson who had become the first
disciple of jigsaw john taught him
everything that he believed in and also
shared some of his knowledge in the
field of mechanical engineering together
they created what would become jigsaw's
signature trap the reverse bear trap the
partnership would be short-lived however
because nelson had to go overseas to
fight in the war
so jon would have to look elsewhere to
find more potential disciples
as he is still working to fight off the
cancer he discovers someone who he
thinks could potentially have what it
takes to be one of his followers
it all begins when john is doing some of
his own research on an alternate
treatment and discovers a doctor in
norway who's been administering an
experimental therapy with a 30 to 40
success rates he goes to visit his
healthcare provider umbrella health
which is run by william easton the man
who had once sponsored the party at
jill's clinic he explains the situation
and requests coverage but william gives
him this copy and paste answer about how
his doctor would already be using the
treatment if it worked how it's not
feasible with john's insurance policy
and that if he seeks this treatment out
independently he'll be dropped from his
current coverage
john responds with one of my favorite
lines that i always make sure to quote
if i ever have to go to the doctor
whenever it's time to pay the
receptionist will just be like okay
cece's world that's 50 000
and then i just do my best john kramer
voice and say you know in the far east
people pay their doctors when they're
healthy
and then she's like what and i say you
think it's the living that will have
ultimate judgment over you
no but i think the reason john reacts
the way he does to mr easton is more out
of principle to make a point about the
health care system rather than for
personal reasons and i think he knew he
was going to die before long and he had
the money to seek out other treatments
but he wanted his legacy to say
something about society which is again
something that a religious icon might do
later that year things would get worse
with his health once again and it was
time to unleash the jigsaw icon out into
the world the public was about to learn
of jigsaw for the first time
in june of 2003 dr lawrence gordon
diagnosed john with an inoperable
frontal lobe tumor or glioblastoma
multiforme of the left temporal lobe
in other words he had a very fast
spreading brain cancer he underwent
chemotherapy to try to kill the cancer
cells and
external beam radiation therapy to try
to remove the tumor nine months later on
march 24 2004
john was found to have progressive
aphasia and right-sided hemoplegia
this means the brain cancer was
affecting his ability to speak and
limiting his ability to move the right
side of his body
see we're learning science here in the
horror history classroom this show is
educational guys it's not just memes
it's not just
memes
[Music]
okay fine but my point is it's not all
memes jon was examined again and dr
gordon and dr denlon discovered a mass
on his left temporal lobe causing his
brain stem to compress the cancer was
also metastatic meaning it was moving to
different parts of the brain or possibly
different parts of the body
a further brain scan indicated signs of
necrosis his brain cells were going to
die as a side effect of the radiation
therapy which was meant to kill the
cancer cells but didn't
necessarily distinguish between good and
bad cells in addition to that he
exhibited edema so his brain was
swelling inside of his skull forcing
them to perform a craniotomy a brain
surgery that requires them to create a
surgical opening through his skull
if you weren't paying attention through
most of that medical jargon basically
all you need to know
was that ya boy was sick and dr denlon
told him that there's no preventative
treatment for what you have
in a very cold and clinical tone john
didn't appreciate that a whole lot his
brain may have had a recurring tumor but
it didn't seem to affect his memory as
he would file dr denlon's lack of
empathy away in his mind to make her
another possible test subject in the
future
in the meantime however dr gordon and dr
denlon were able to improve his
condition enough so he could be released
from the hospital to enjoy what time he
had left at home
however he had other ideas of how he
wanted to spend his precious hours
ironically we don't actually see his
first public victims even though this
area between march 2004 and october 2004
has been covered to death in the movies
but basically what we do know is that
there were at least three or so traps
that were held in which none of the
victims made it
the reason i think this is because the
next death that we do see is the death
of seth baxter in the pendulum trap
which was created by detective mark
hoffman to make it look like seth was
another victim of jigsaw but in order
for this copycat crime to make sense
that means there had to have been other
jigsaw traps that were discovered by the
public in the first place
even though we don't see them on this
list of jigsaw victims in saw 5.
maybe there's another page to this list
that we don't see or maybe they were all
so badly mutilated that they could not
be identified it certainly wasn't
because the creators of this franchise
are human and a mistake was made
in these first three public victims a
few conventions are established like the
use of a pre-recorded tape featuring
billy the puppet reading the rules of
each trap out to the victim the idea
that jon is physically present at the
sight of each test and the fact that a
jigsaw puzzle piece is cut out of the
flesh of each subject as a result of
this the police and the press coined the
name
jigsaw and jon became known as the
jigsaw killer my name's john
how do you like to be called jigsaw it
was the police and the press
who coined the nickname jigsaw i never
encouraged or claimed that
the jigsaw piece i cut from my subjects
was only ever meant to be a symbol that
that subject was missing something
mark hoffman used these elements in his
copycat jigsaw trap but jon had already
been keeping an eye on him for other
reasons so he found out immediately and
decided to test him as well in a crude
trap call to the shotgun chair which
prevented hoffman from moving his arms
if he didn't want to
you know blow his head off the reason
that hoffman is tested is because he
didn't give his subject a second chance
everybody deserves a chance and you get
a chance
and you get a chance hoffman is gonna
get one too because jon realizes that
the two of them are not too far apart in
their intentions
they both want to bring justice to the
city but jon believes he has a better
way of going about it because of his god
complex so he brings hoffman
on as his next disciple to make sure he
stays in line jon threatens that the
truth about hoffman being seth baxter's
killer will automatically be released if
anything happens to him so hoffman is
forced to work under jon and jon hopes
that this will help him see the light
and he starts to agree with jon's
methods
in order to start this transformation
jon takes hoffman along as he sets up
the next two traps the two of them would
double team a man named paul leahy
and leave him in the razor wire maze
trap paul was a former addict that jon
had first met at jill's clinic and he
had since turned to cutting himself to
feed his addiction the maze seemed to be
an updated version of cecil's second
trap and paul was required to crawl
through
thus cutting himself again to get out
the irony
is that if you want to die you just have
to stay where you are
but if you want to live you'll have to
cut yourself again
the hope was that this more painful
punishment would get paul to appreciate
the life that he had
but it was once again in vain and paul
was unable to survive
the crime scene was quote unquote
investigated by hoffman but the deputy
coroner and the police force alison
carey introduced two new investigators
to the equation
steven singh and david tapp jigsaw would
keep tabs on them from here on out and
later decided to make them future jigsaw
victims
before this i think you could make the
arguments at least that everyone he had
tested
even if you don't want to say they
deserved it they were bad people not
including nelson who didn't really end
up getting tested but sing and tap only
end up on jigsaw's naughty list because
they're trying to bring a serial killer
to justice this is both the psychopathy
and the god complex inside of jon really
taking over and skewing his perception
of reality
these two psychological conditions cause
him to invent reasons to punish sing and
tap so that nobody can stop him he tried
to tell himself that they deserve to be
tested because they valued the glory of
catching jigsaw over the preservation of
human life but it was really just an
excuse to strike down those who opposed
him
so the god complex told him that nobody
should threaten his power but his
psychopathy told him that he was doing
the right thing by putting them through
nearly inescapable tests jon set up a
new workshop in an abandoned mannequin
factory on stygian street
there he would work on the creation of
his next major game the bathroom game
and he would create a trap for sing and
tap so that they would be killed if they
tried to confront or stop him he does
this by filming the videotapes he plays
for his victims in front of recognizable
graffiti to lure the two cops into his
territory but they would not show up
there for at least a few weeks
in the meantime he had another subject
to test and once again enlisted the help
of hoffman the victim was named
mark wilson jon found out that mark was
faking an illness in order to scam
others so he tests him using the
flammable jelly trap
mark needed to obtain the combination to
a safe containing an antidote using a
candle to read the clues hidden
on the walls the floor was covered in
sharp glass and one wrong move would
ignite the flammable jelly smeared all
over his body
that is why it's called the flammable
jelly trap after setting this trap up
hoffman tries to warn jon that tap is
onto him but jon
being the manipulative mastermind that
he already is is already one step
ahead of it
[Music]
one day during his treatments at the
angel of mercy hospital jon steals a pen
light from his oncologist dr gordon and
passes it on to hoffman instructing him
to leave it behind at the flammable
jelly trap crime scene in order to throw
the other investigators off
the plan worked and it gave jon a little
bit more freedom when it came to his
next trap which would involve two more
former patients of the homeward-bound
clinic
this trap would take place in may of
2004 five months before the events of
the bathroom game that was five months
ago
and the players this time were two drug
addicts named amanda young and donny
greco this was another example of jigsaw
believing his judgments are supreme
but in reality the scenario he creates
is unfair amanda is told she must
retrieve the key from the stomach of her
dead cellmate in order to remove the
reverse bear trap and prevent it from
tearing open her head
however when she begins she finds that
dany is not actually dead
just paralyzed but she has to kill him
to get the key we're not even at the
start of the first movie yet and jon's
already breaking his own rules
and very loudly yelled ones at that
everybody deserves a chance
as i discussed in my saw episode of
things you missed it is possible that
donnie already had a second chance in a
trap of his own off-screen somewhere
what's most likely happening here is
that jigsaw has developed a bit of a
taste for violence through his previous
victims it's another trait of the
psychopath the need for stimulation
ironically this makes him no better than
the addicts that he's so keen on
punishing
because they're addicted to drugs and
he's essentially addicted to putting
people in traps he's made himself the
judge
jury and executioner and he's begun to
take joy in the power that this gives
him
what makes him even more dangerous is
the fact that he's super intelligent and
knows that he has to be sneaky about
what he's doing in order for it to
continue
at this point jigsaw is already a
full-fledged monster after amanda
unlocks the reverse bear trap from her
head billy the puppet wheels up on a
tricycle and congratulates her
congratulations you are still alive
most people are so ungrateful to be
alive
but not you not anymore john waits in
her apartment for her to get home and
tells her not to be afraid because her
life has just begun
amanda would become his next disciple
she was the first survivor of a game to
actually believe that the experience had
helped her overcome something
and felt that her days of taking drugs
were behind her now that she came to
appreciate life
for this reason john saw great potential
in her to be the one to continue his
work so he began to work more closely
with her as he developed his next game
hoping to hone her skills and get her up
to speed with hoffman
two weeks later in mid to late may jon
predicts that sing and tap are close to
discovering his workshop he may have
known this because of his excellent
ability to anticipate the actions of
others but may have also been aided by
hoffman who was still a police officer
and may have been looking over tap's
shoulder to warn jon about when he was
getting close
he starts wearing a bulletproof vest
round under his robes as a precaution
and kidnaps a man named
jeff rydenauer the reason that jigsaw
wanted to test jeff is unknown because
his tape is never discovered however if
we use the non-canon video game
saw two flesh and blood as a clue it
would seem that jeff had attempted
suicide and thus
jon felt that he did not cherish his
life he imprisons jeff in a trap known
as the drill chair
and waits for sing and tap to find him
one day when he walks into his workshop
he realizes that
someone has been there and prepares for
a confrontation he starts the drill
chair by stepping on a switch on the
ground and explains that it will kill
jeff in 20 seconds if the detectives
can't find the key
so basically they have to choose between
saving his life and capturing jigsaw
this is another example of him bending
his own rules to benefit himself
unless there's some off-screen scene
with jeff failing his first test he's
not really being given a second chance
he also claims that he despises murder
killing is
distasteful okay calm down dude if you
wake up your parents the sleepover's
gonna be over but the fact that john
physically starts a machine designed to
drill through jeff's head is no
different than him pulling a trigger and
shooting someone
i've never murdered anyone in my life
the decisions are up to them
from what we can tell jeff never really
had the option to escape as many of the
others did
because if somebody else were doing this
jon would see it as unjust but because
sing and tap are coming after him and he
views himself as a god he'll break any
rules he wants to bring them down
my favorite example of a god complex in
fiction is light yagami from death note
and we see a similar thing happen with
him
he starts off by only killing criminals
but then he tries to kill the detective
l who was trying to bring him to justice
jigsaw's way of testing the two cops is
to see if they try to save jeff or
capture jigsaw
singh focuses on freeing the victim but
tap goes after jon and as a result fails
the test and gets his throat slashed
then
singh makes the same mistake and goes
after jon probably not wanting the
mission to have been in vain but jon who
was always prepared for any scenario was
prepared for this too
sang chases him down the stairs into a
hallway where the quadruple gun trap is
set up this one is pretty simple
if you trip a hidden fishing wire these
guns hidden overhead will kill you
jon steps over the wire safely and singh
shoots him with his own gun
jon's bulletproof vest absorbs the
gunshot but he wisely stays on the
ground and waits for singh to approach
trip the wire and get himself killed
[Laughter]
before getting back up and fleeing the
workshop for good i think one of the
reasons that he believed he'd be able to
pull something like this off was that he
had endured so much pain from his cancer
treatment that getting knocked to the
ground with a gunshot impact even at the
frail age of 50 at this point was not
much in comparison
he expresses a similar sentiment during
another game a year later
you officer but i'm a cancer patient
how could you possibly put me in any
more pain that i'm already in
detective tap ends up surviving the
throat slash so john has to abandon his
workshop at the mannequin factory and
relocate to a property that would later
be called the nerve gas house i would
theorize that this was part of the urban
renewal project
the housing project he abandoned at the
end of his engineering career there
seemed to be several of these houses
throughout the city but this particular
one has been outfitted with a network of
underground tunnels and hidden rooms and
one of these rooms was a dilapidated
bathroom that john had perfectly
configured to be the site of the next
big game
if jigsaw's life is a puzzle a
combination of the various pieces that
make up his identity we need to assemble
those pieces in order to fully
understand him
the same approach can be taken to
understand some of his games the barn
game brought together
people who had wronged others but
refused to admit their mistakes and seek
the confession from each of them they
were all unified by that but were
otherwise not connected in any
significant way
so for jon's next game the bathroom game
of october 2004 he strategically chose
subjects who were all different pieces
of the same puzzle
and the centerpiece that connected to
all of the others was his oncologist at
the angel of mercy hospital
dr lawrence gordon the first subject
that john captured for this game was
named zepp hindle he was an orderly at
the hospital who actually cared for john
a lot and treated him very well but
unfortunately for him
jon kind of needed him to make the whole
thing work we don't find out why zepp
was tested by jigsaw however this is
another one where we can turn to the
supplemental non-canon material for
possible clues
saw rebirth was a comic and eventually
motion comic that aimed to give a little
more backstory about john cramer this
isn't an official entry in the series
because it does contradict details from
some of the movies but i think it's
relatively harmless to use this
explanation of why jigsaw decided to
test zap i'm gonna roll the clip but as
a fair warning the casting of the voices
isn't the best the first voice you're
going to hear is supposed to be zepp and
the narrator is john kramer so with that
in mind let's roll the clip
remember the dark was a real shoulder to
cry on huh cold
i wanted basses a lot of them what are
you talking about
they're all screwing around on their
wives i sure won't be in that way when
i'm a doctor
the orderly had issues of his own now
that my own life was slipping away
i paid closer attention to the lives of
others so it seems like zep's big flaw
was that he was a gossip
jigsaw injects him with the poison and
forces him to help facilitate the game
if he wants to get the antidote
zepp was most likely responsible for the
kidnapping of dr gordon while amanda's
job was to get adam stanheit adam was a
photographer hired by detective tap to
spy on gordon because tap suspected
gordon of being jigsaw
before amanda abducted him though jon
performs a ceremony to celebrate her
rebirth the ceremony seems to be another
example of jon trying to make his mo
into a religious experience he dons the
black and red robes yet again in a
candlelit room and asks her to
essentially make vows of devotion to him
interestingly in the saw 3 official
soundtrack the music that plays during
the scene is called baptism and if you
listen closely there's a coral chant in
the background
giving the feeling of a church choir
[Music]
he leaves amanda to it and heads to the
bathroom to make the final preparations
when she shows up with the unconscious
atom he pauses the glam and gore
tutorial he was watching he instructs
her on what to do with adam as he pours
a bucket of fake blood onto the ground
and prepares himself for his most
ambitious game yet
it's time to start our game oh boy i'll
get the controllers
i won't play your game i won't
oh wait i think i misunderstood john
injects himself with a serum that is
supposed to slow down his heart rate
relax his muscles and make him less
noticeable as he pretends
keyword pretends to be dead on the floor
in the middle of the bathroom and amanda
takes all the other materials hits the
light and closes the door on lawrence
adam and john who has a gun in his left
hand and a tape recorder in the other
it would seem that he's also hiding a
small remote in his palm or something
that has the ability to send a shock to
adam or lawrence all jose altuve style
the goal for lawrence in this game was
to kill adam before time runs out and
the goal for adam was just to escape
he was tested because he spent more and
more time spying on other people rather
than examining his own life
adam and gordon are supposed to be
enemies in this game but they try to
secretly work together to escape
not knowing that the man in the center
of the room is alive listening and also
the man responsible for their
imprisonment so when they develop a plan
to make it look like lawrence had killed
adam with the poison to try to fool zepp
who is watching via the camera it
doesn't work because jon hears
everything that they said and shocks at
him to show zepp that he wasn't really
dead later when lawrence seems to have
lost all hope jigsaw gives him a buzz
[Music]
which i saw is him trying one last ditch
effort to reinvigorate gordon's passion
to make him stop feeling sorry for
himself and to ignite a fury to motivate
him to try to pass his test i'd say it
works
okay fine roll the clip one last time
that never gets old gordon ends up
cutting off his own foots to escape the
shackle and in one desperate final
attempt to save his family
pretends to kill adam again this time
using the gun i find it very interesting
that jon doesn't use the electric shock
again to test if adam is really dead
it might be that he actually doesn't
suspect it the first time he knew to be
skeptical because he could hear lawrence
and adam whispering to each other in the
dark but on the second attempt i'm
pretty sure that dr gordon just gives
adam a wink i've theorized that it's
while
his head is turned away from the camera
right here jon has to keep his eyes
closed so he doesn't know that this was
another fake
out attack and lawrence's acting was
good enough to sell that it was real
i know they're gonna be people who think
it's out of character for someone as
smart as jon to be fooled like that so
if you have your own theory as to why he
didn't shock adam right here let me know
in the comments
at the end of the game dr gordon is the
only one who manages to limp away alive
and that leaves adam alone in the
bathroom with jon who adam still
believes to be dead
then this happens
[Music]
i swear this isn't the beginning of a
mattress commercial this is actually
what happens
and if you do get a mattress commercial
i swear it's a complete coincidence
[Applause]
did you know that the wrong mattress
protector can ruin the feel of your
mattress
after getting to his feet jigsaw informs
adam that the key to his chain was
inside the bathtub which was now
unreachable because the tub had drained
adam tries to grab zep's gun off the
ground to attack jigsaw but one last
electric shock sends it flying from his
hands
[Music]
jon was now out of danger but he was not
done with his tasks for that evening he
leaves the bathroom to go find dr gordon
after seeing the way that the doctor had
handled the situation under pressure he
realized that he would be an
excellent ally and having passed his
test he'd be a prime candidate to become
a new disciple
he catches up to him and finds him on
the verge of passing out because of the
blood loss
john splashes some water on his face
while congratulating him on surviving
he helps clean up the wound and
eventually physically rehabilitates him
giving him a prosthetic foot and taking
him on as the next accomplice
jon would treat dr gordon differently
than his other students he was already
beginning to sense potential problems
with mark and amanda who he'd suspected
of having
dark ulterior motives to harm the
victims of the traps rather than save
them
he feared that his platform the name
jigsaw would be misused after his
passing so using dr gordon he set up a
system of checks and balances by keeping
gordon's involvement a secret from the
other apprentices he had a hidden weapon
to help preserve his legacy
i should note that nelson was still
overseas fighting in america's iraq war
so
jon didn't know if he'd be coming back
or if he would be reliable anymore
at some point over the next year jigsaw
continues carrying out smaller traps to
test the people he deems to have lost
their appreciation for life
one of these was a woman named joan who
survived her trap but decided not to
become one of jigsaw's followers for
unknown reasons
she does however gain a stronger
appreciation for her life
and tells her story on the news
that pure moment of absolute horror gave
me light
and as wrong as this may seem
i'm better for endearing it the
broadcast reaches a man named bobby
dagon who is inspired by her
transformation
and perhaps more significantly her
potential marketability the smart thing
for bobby to do would be to get in
contact with her and offered a ghost
write a book about her jigsaw experience
for a percentage of the profit but what
he does instead is write his own book
where he pretends to be a jigsaw victim
jon takes issue with this for similar
reasons to him taking issue with hoffman
impersonating one of his traps and
confronts him at a book signing
in ancient egypt if you were speaking
under oath you were required to say
if i'm lying take me to the quarries
that mean anything to you after getting
his copy signed john removes the cover
with the photo of bobby's face on it
telling him that he won't need it now
that they've met
i think this is john's little way of
telling bobby that he's the real jigsaw
obviously bobby isn't supposed to figure
it out right away but he's basically
saying that he's so intelligent that
he'll always remember bobby's face
even from such a short meeting and he's
kind of hinting that they could meet
again
they don't meet again though the task of
testing bobby dagan would fall
on one of jigsaw's disciples the next
big game jon would plan would be even
more complex than the last this game
would involve two locations and as with
the bathroom game he planned to place
himself in the center of one of them to
facilitate things
he also placed amanda in the midst of
the action in the other location to make
sure that the rules were followed
around october of 2005 it was finally
time for the game to take place
the first half of the game which was
created by jigsaw takes place in the
previously mentioned
nerve gas house it contains a series of
criminals who all had ties to one cop
named eric matthews one of these
criminals was a con man named abby tate
who john convinced to help kidnap the
other seven players
then jon brought in hoffman to sedate
and bring in abi as the eighth and final
contestant
after some finishing touches to one of
the traps within the game called the
magnum ihole the nerve gas house was
ready in this game
each member was breathing in a deadly
nerve gas and was tasked with completing
a trap of their own in order to win an
antidote
each of them was a real criminal who was
framed for a different crime they did
not commit
by eric matthews except for one daniel
matthews was eric matthew's son
he was also a criminal although his
crimes were much more childish part of
the game involved them all figuring out
that they were tied to matthews in some
way
the second half of the game was created
by amanda so amanda was inside of john's
portion of the game and jon was inside
amanda's portion the second half took
place at an unused steel plant called
wilson steel which had been the location
of john's main workshop over the past
year amanda possibly with the help of
jon had set up video monitors of the
events that had already taken place at
the nerve gas hives this was the main
motivation for detective matthews to
participate in the game he would see his
son in danger and be forced to play
along to add insult to injury he
re-recorded daniel's voicemail greeting
reach daniel's phone he's not in right
now
that actually brings up a lot of
questions for me like did he re-record
the voicemails of every victim
and if so why wasn't that included as
bonus content on the special edition
dvds of each saw movie
promotional dvd
the bone of zack hello he's not in right
now because he didn't agree with my
opinion on
salsa amanda is able to get daniel
through john's half of the game at the
nerve gas house and daniel is stowed
safely and secretly within jigsaw's
headquarters but to lure detective
matthews into his trap
jon uses another trap which contains a
clue about the location
of jigsaw's workshop
jigsaw wood for the first time in his
known history enlist the help of his
secret asset dr lawrence gordon for one
of his traps the victim this time was
named michael marks a police informant
who was another former patient of the
homeward bound clinic
jigsaw felt michael was not worthy of
the life he'd been given because as an
informant he spent all his time spying
on others and he'd become a rat or a
snitch
this shows us that jigsaw has gone even
further down the rabbit hole
jon does exactly what michael marx does
to find victims who he believes are
wrongdoers
if anything jon himself is more guilty
of this because of the number of people
he's keeping tabs on but his reasoning
goes back
once again to the god complex causing
him to believe that he's allowed to do
it but others our society as a whole is
not
michael wakes up wearing a device around
his neck called the venus fly trap which
will clamp down and impale his face
if he's unable to obtain the key which
gordon has hidden behind his right eye
jigsaw asks him to look inward rather
than outward and give up one of the eyes
that he relies so much on to spy on
criminals michael fails his test and jon
takes a jigsaw piece out of him and
leaves a message behind for detective
matthews telling him to look closer i
also wonder if his misspelling of
matthew's last name was another sign
that the brain cancer was really getting
to his head
matthews would take a closer look and
discover that the victim was one of his
informants and that the steel used to
construct the trap
was from wilson's steel plant a location
that john knew matthews was familiar
with because it played a part in a case
from his past
matthews leads his team there just in
time to catch a jigsaw eating his sunday
morning cocoa puffs
i'm just imagining john kramer doing
that
like just just seeing this old cancer
patient just start jumping around and
losing it
when you taste the cocoa the swat team
comes in and handcuffs jigsaw matthews
mocks him by leaning in and saying
is this close enough um yeah
matthews orders his men to book jigsaw
but as i mentioned earlier in this
lesson john takes control of the
situation by saying he'll have to stay
in place
the cops find the video monitors and jon
confirms that the kid on the screens is
indeed
matthew's son daniel his facial
expression as he does this is a sick
example of how his psychotic tendencies
have evolved i spoke
earlier about the increasing need for
repeated stimulation sometimes seen in
psychopaths this occurs because at the
beginning
jon believed that he was doing the world
of service by punishing criminals and
other people that he's judged to have
lost their way he tortured these
individuals using his traps and so his
brain came to associate
doing a good thing with doing a very bad
thing putting others in pain so as a
result he starts to like the idea of
hurting his victims
it's your son daniel you remember him
don't you [ __ ] no who is you piece of
[ __ ] what is he doing on that monitor
well i haven't looked at the monitors
for some time so it would be hard for me
to say
but i would imagine that um he's
cowering in a corner with a look on his
face
and he has an even bigger smile on his
face when he describes the torture that
daniel might be going through in detail
he has about two hours before the gas
creeping into his nervous system
begins to break down his body tissue and
he begins to bleed from every orifice he
has
oh yes there will be blood
i feel like there's a paul thomas
anderson joke to be made here but i
don't know what it is so i'm just gonna
put this humorous if not irrelevant meme
all right i think that's been on screen
for long enough jon explains to matthews
how he can see his son again if he
simply sits with jon until the game ends
without resorting to dirty police work
such as
evidence tampering ha bet you thought i
was gonna say
matthews reluctantly agrees to sit down
with jigsaw who tries to get through to
him and make him realize the error of
his past ways for how far jon has
strayed from his original intention to
help people i do think that he actually
does a good job during this game and
doing his best to get matthews to
actually win the game we also learn a
little bit more about jigsaw's mantra
the reason that he wants to build a
following and try to ch
he explains that charles darwin's theory
of evolution no longer applies to the
modern man because we live in a society
where it's easy to survive without
having the edge or the will to survive
that's why john views his subjects as
having not cherished their lives then he
goes on to explain that his past with
the cancer and the lost child
changed that for him but before he's
able to give matthews that same epiphany
the detective walks away in a rage
that would be the closest jon would get
to converting him to the church of
jigsaw eric ends up resorting to
destroying jon's blueprints which jon
points out is not the proper move from
an officer who should be collecting
evidence but jon really wants eric to
succeed so he gives him another chance
to turn it around
eventually matthews snaps when he sees a
criminal on the monitor coming after his
son and decides to go to his go-to
method
brutality he breaks jon's finger
destroys the walkie-talkie which is
basically his way of saying that he
won't be doing things by the book
anymore and puts his gun into jon's
mouth as he continually threatens him
at that point jon has seen enough he's
realized that matthews is past the point
of no return and that there is no
hope for him over
jigsaw realized that there was no hope
for detective eric matthews after he
turned a violent hand against him and
decided it was time to take him to the
house where the nerve gas game had been
held
this was all part of his game plan
though or i guess technically amanda's
game plan though it's hard to imagine
that jon didn't play a big part in it
because jon's most dangerous asset is
unlike many other horror movie villains
his intelligence
we've seen him use his masterful
understanding of engineering to his
advantage but he was also helped by an
impressive comprehension of the human
mind to put it into a term that i find
to be almost comically appropriate i
would say that jon was a master of
game theory hello internet welcome to
game theory
so i've been doing some research and i
found out what if shaggy from scooby doo
was a stoner the whole time
uh no that's offensive i am not a stoner
and don't do drugs or you might wake up
with a reverse bear trap
but i recently learned that the beloved
internet show game theory is actually
named after an actual concept called
game theory and yes i do plan on
continuing to pronounce it like that
game theory is the study of how players
in a game will strategize in different
situations it's basically the science of
decision making the development of
game theory was first developed by
mathematician
john von neumann to try to bolster his
poker skills john kramer used some of
those concepts to make his games
adaptable to some of the most likely
decisions that his players may make he's
thought out most if not
all possible outcomes for each decision
but uses game
theory to determine which scenarios are
most likely to happen and spend the most
time developing those outcomes
yes it is more complicated than that but
as i've said before we don't do math
here in the horror history classroom so
i'll leave it in the simplest terms
john's understanding of game theory is
the reason he was able to sidestep cecil
the reason that he could count on zepp
to show up in the bathroom and the
reason he was comfortable putting his
life on the line at the wilson steel
planet when matthews loses his game
jon has already predicted that matthews
will do what benefits him most in the
moment by threatening jon and forcing
him to give directions to the nerve gas
house jon uses the fact that matthews
was thinking independently from the rest
of his unit to his advantage while jon
takes him to the real nerve gas house
the police tech team follows the video
signal to another house where the
pre-recorded videos are being played
back from
remember how i theorized that there were
several houses all part of john's urban
renewal project i think the fake out
nerve gas house is just another one of
those houses
when john and matthews arrive at the
real house jon is hanging onto his life
by a thread and hands over a key
not disclosing that this would be the
key that locks in eric matthews face
now you are locked away helpless
and alone game over
that's my favorite one if you can't tell
amanda attempted to leave eric matthews
for dead but jigsaw seemingly seeing
great potential in the guy and perhaps
sensing that he was close to getting
through to him decided to give him one
more chance he saved matthews and kept
him in a holding cell for the next six
months during this period
jon realizes that he's running on
borrowed time he knows his days are
extremely numbered at this point and
still has many targets that he wants to
punish
most importantly though he still needs
to decide which of his disciples now
consisting of amanda young
mark hoffman and lawrence gordon would
continue his work after his death he
created games for each of them as a
final test amanda's game was planned to
take place with
jon on his deathbed while hoffman's
would be a postmortem challenge
it's not clear if gordon's final test
was detailed in the films it could be
that the preparations that he helped
with for some of the other traps were
part of his final test or it could be
that it happened off-screen
he also hopes to get his ex-wife back on
his side by showing her that his
rehabilitation methods had saved amanda
even when the medical approach at jill's
clinic could not
i brought proof that it worked
amanda hello jill
but there are way more plans traps and
games that jigsaw didn't have time for
in his lifetime
he records a tape for his ex-wife jill
and leaves it for her in his will
instructing her to carry out a game to
help balance the power of jigsaw when
he's gone
this included hoffman's final test but
also five others who were a part of
william easton's umbrella health the
insurance company that had prohibited
jon from seeking out alternative
treatments to his cancer the box he
leaves behind is locked so that nobody
without the key could get into it and he
would hold on to the key for a while
longer
he also pre-records the tapes that would
play during the games and traps for
other people like detective carrie a
repeat offender named troy
swat officer rigg a guy named trevor who
we know nothing about jon's former
business partner art blank
another pair of tapes for trevor and our
blank in case they survived the first
one
a pimp named brenda an evil motel
manager named ivan a pair of abusive
parents named rex and morgan an fbi
agent named lindsey perez another fbi
agent named peter strom
five citizens who all played a part in a
building fire scandal a malicious
moneylender named simone a malicious
moneylender named eddie a sensationless
reporter named pamela jenkins a love
triangle consisting of three young
people brad dina and ryan
a gang of four rap medal love and
racists and the man who once tried to
pretend to be a jigsaw victim would
finally become one
bobby dagen keep in mind jigsaw didn't
assume the outcome of any game
so he also probably had multiple tapes
for each person to take all of the
possible results into account
in addition to all of that he left one
final set of instructions that jill was
supposed to hand off to dr gordon
watch over jill and should anything
happen to her
i want you to act immediately on my path
in return for that i will keep no more
secrets from you
i hope old johnny charged up some extra
camera and audio recorder batteries
because that's a lot of recording
going on for jigsaw but not as much
recording as i've had to do to make this
video so with that in mind i think it's
only fair that i take a little break
before we get to the final game
of john's love
it is likely that john knew the games
taking place in april of 2006 would be
his last regardless of the outcome
two games would take place that day the
one involving rig blank matthews and
hoffman was designed by jon but would be
carried out by hoffman while the other
game involving lynne denlon
jeff denlon amanda young and jon was
created by jon and would be facilitated
by jon the game was originally gonna
feature jeff denlon going through a
series of trials to try to forgive
people involved in a road accident that
resulted in his young son's death the
idea was that if he made it to the end
of the game he'd be forced to confront
amanda who is implied to be his captor
just restraint would be tested by
choosing whether or not to kill amanda
upon reaching the end while amanda's
restraint would be tested by making sure
she didn't sabotage jeff's trial as she
did to some of her other victims in the
past
jigsaw was worried that amanda was only
involved because she enjoyed punishing
the victims and did not want to see them
actually succeed
and pass their tests and rehabilitate as
she supposedly had
seeing amanda sabotage her recent traps
to make them unwinnable disturbed jon
and may have made him start to lose
faith in his methods or at the very
least
lose faith in amanda the entire
operation he had built was founded on
the idea that amanda had been the first
one to be rehabilitated
the prime example of how suffering can
cause a person to be reborn and lead a
better life
he considered amanda to be the closest
person to truly understanding him so he
would probably be quite defeated if she
were to fail her final test now
after two years of training to make
matters worse she seemed to be
developing a rivalry with the other
known prospective candidate to continue
jon's work detective hoffman
hoffman's training with john was also
ongoing and john did his best with the
limited time he had to teach hoffman to
walk the fine line that jigsaw is
supposed to walk he must respect the
lives of those test subjects he captured
but also prepare to see them suffer in
order to achieve retribution for their
sins
the day these games were held was on
april 28th 2006.
before the fun begins jon's ex-wife
shows up at the meatpacking plants to
try to plead with him to get him to stop
his work
instead of listening to her he gives her
the key to the box left to her in his
will
and tells her she'll know what to do
with it when the time comes with that
jon feels he's done everything he can do
and asked amanda to take him to his
deathbed his final game was about to
begin and his assistants went to go
retrieve the players dr lynn denlin
and the morning father jeff demlin
hoffman got done capturing jeff and
placing him at the start of his trial
moments before amanda got back with lynn
and he used this time to have one last
meeting with john it turns out that
hoffman shared the same concerns about
amanda letting her emotions get in the
way of her giving her victims a fair
chance to survive
jon rewards hoffman for his honest work
so far by giving him a protection that
amanda does not have
a non-immediate amanda was already a
known accomplice to jigsaw
the police and fbi would have figured
that out when they saw her help daniel
matthews out of the nerve gas house
since daniel ended up being stowed in
jigsaw's workshop
the fbi did suspect there was another
accomplice but did not know with
certainty that it was hoffman so john's
willingness to keep hoffman's
involvement a secret showed that he had
more faith in hoffman than he had in
amanda in exchange for keeping this
anonymity he does ask hoffman to carry
out one more task and hands him a file
with instructions on a future game which
would test ashley kuzon charles
salomon brit stevenson scott malik and
luba gibbs who all played some part in
causing and covering up a deadly fire
what's this it's time to play a game
those would be the final words john said
to his longest tenured students who
slipped out a secret door before heading
over to the room where the final trial
of daniel rigg would take place
moments later amanda arrived with lynn
denlon so their own game was about to
begin
hello doctor jon explains that he was
once her patient and blames her for
telling him that he's going to die in
such a cold clinical tone of voice he
claims that she's dead on the inside
after leaving her husband and neglecting
her daughter but when john delivers his
second most used phrase from his list of
top 10 phrases
what do i want i want to play a game
he's actually looking at amanda
signifying that this is her test as much
as it is dr denlin's this would be her
final chance to prove that she can let a
game play out fairly without her desire
for revenge and bloodthirst getting in
the way
i mean obviously there's nothing fair
about any of jigsaw's games but you get
what i mean when jon states the rules he
simply says he is testing her will to
keep someone alive which could apply to
both
lin and amanda lin is required to keep
john alive and amanda is required to
keep lynn alive
if jon dies his heart rate monitor will
stop causing lin's shotgun collar to
shoot her in the head whereas if lynn
dies jeff will come through the door at
the end of his trial and get revenge on
the first person he sees
amanda the theme of the game is
forgiveness can a father forgive the
people involved in the premature death
of his son
can amanda forgive the victims who had
faltered in life as she once had and can
lindenlin forgive the man responsible
for kidnapping her entire family by
doing her best job to keep him alive as
long as possible
as usual with jigsaw each of these
people were pieces of his puzzle and
they would all interlock together at the
end his confidence that each of them
will end up coming together is another
example of his mastery of
game theory amanda would keep tabs on
jeff's progress as dr denlon began to
treat jon she believes john's brain is
herniating and suggests that they take
him to a hospital and john watches
helplessly
as amanda loses her cool and goes off on
the doctor basically telling her that
she needs to perform an operation in
this room
normally jigsaw would not really
interfere with anything that might
change the result of his games but in
this instance he snaps at amanda i think
that's because she was the only one that
had seemingly recovered from her
addictions she was the only ray of hope
that could make jon believe that his
treatment methods actually worked so he
desperately wanted her to pass her test
so that he could die
thinking that he had actually been
helping his test subjects all along of
course john was
completely delusional at this point he
hadn't actually helped out anybody other
than himself and would soon show much
more quantifiable signs of his
deteriorating sanity but his sanity
wasn't the only thing that had slipped
because moments later he would go into a
life-threatening micronic episode
john must have been very aware that he
was getting close to the end of his life
because it was very shortly after
bringing lynn denlon into the picture
that he convulsed into a dangerous state
that required the combined efforts of dr
denlon and amanda to get the oxygen
flowing back to his brain and save his
life
jon was left very weak after this but
refused to let that stop him from
continuing to work on his legacy
he may have been crazy but i gotta
admire his work ethic just like you
should admire my work ethic to get you
to buy this merch you can click the link
in the i think it was while lynn and
amanda were out
arguing in the next room when jigsaw
recorded the tape for detective hoffman
to find after his death of course he
couldn't guarantee that hoffman would be
the only one to hear it so he had to
speak in very general terms not
revealing the fact that they were
actually working together
are you there detective if so
you are probably the last band standing
now perhaps you will succeed when the
others have failed
you think you will walk away untested
i promise that my work will
continue john placed this tape next to
his bed and as lynn prepared for the
next operation amanda came in to inform
him that jeff had passed through the
first room of his trial jon let amanda
know about an envelope that he had
hoffman hide in his desk we never find
out what this note was supposed to say
it was most likely supposed to offer a
man to some strength in words but
hoffman switched out the message
if you want to know more about that you
can watch the hofmann and amanda horror
history episodes when he sees amanda
becoming overwhelmed with emotion he
once again tries to intervene to get her
back on the right path
i can't do this you can
you can you're stronger now
this is another example of his blind
ambition to prove that his
rehabilitation process works despite
all evidence pointing to the fact that
it doesn't the american psychiatric
association notes that psychotic
behavior can include an over-inflated
self-image and extreme cockiness it
seems that jon has reached that stage
and he can't accept that he was wrong
about something especially after
spending his last three years holding
these games with the intention of
proving that his test subjects were
missing something and that torturing
them in his traps would help them find
it
after amanda watches jeff complete the
next room she reports back to jon who is
surprised at the rate that he is
progressing but despite his quick
advancement the outcome of the game
would depend entirely on what was about
to happen next
jon gets a haircut something that i
could use right about now
if only you knew in preparation of the
brain surgery that lin was about to
perform this would prevent the brain
from pushing up against john's skull and
theoretically reduces headaches and
improve his motor skills while it was
possible to use numbing agents jon had
to be awake and alert for this procedure
which involved dr denlon drilling into
his skull and cutting open a window
using this little saw blade
get it cause saw that's the name of the
franchise
something about this procedure triggers
some memories in his brain of a picnic
he went on when he was married to jill
which he had recorded on his camcorder
i'm sure that tape is right there on the
shelf at home next to all his other home
videos
that you are in freedom during the
hallucination jon tries to tell his wife
i love you but that causes it to look
like he's telling
lynn denlon he loves her making amanda
get super jealous and causing her to
storm out
just get out of here you stupid dumb
animal
once again dr denlon's efforts are able
to buy john a little more time and it
seems as if she's actually starting to
change her attitude for example we see
her put her wedding ring back on as if
to suggest that seeing jon fighting for
more time made her appreciate her time
with her husband
amanda is still in jealous girlfriend
mode a very serious mental disease that
i discussed in great detail in her own
horror history episode and she comes in
and starts kissing jon's face and neck
lynn tells her that jon is passed out
and can't hear her and again amanda's
temper flares up and she threatens to
kill lynn once again jigsaw has to
intervene and scold her
wait a minute jon weren't you supposed
to be asleep
so you mean to tell me that you just
gained consciousness and had a full
understanding of what was going on in
the two seconds between when this
happened and when this happened
and you were totally passed out and not
pretending to be asleep when amanda was
all over you right here
i see you john kramer i see you
meanwhile jeff continues on through his
trial eventually making it to the room
where he has the opportunity to save his
son's killer from what jon considers to
be his personal favorite trap
the rag the fact that jon even has a
favorite torture device is proof that he
had developed a psychological dependence
on the feeling that he got from hurting
others and this was no longer solely
about curing people
the trap is also a modern day crucifix
which adds credence to his god complex
and development of his teachings as a
religion
back in the operation room jon asked lin
to talk about her new husband causing
lin to defend her marriage against him
which is essentially what he wants he
wants her to get passionate and take
back her life
she begs for him to let her go free and
right as he takes her hand amanda walks
in
causing more jealous rage jon sends her
off
it does seem a little counterproductive
for jigsaw to do something to piss off
amanda like this when he really wants
her to pass her test
it could be that he knew she would have
to endorse some emotional turmoil in
order to prove that she's able to handle
her emotions when he's no longer around
but i don't think he was really in the
mind of
giving his victims proper tests at this
point i think more what was going on is
he sensed he was close to her
breakthrough with lin and didn't want
amanda to interrupt it
why settle for one successful patient
when he could possibly have two
if you make it through this land you're
going to thank me one day just as amanda
did
as he continued to talk with lynn he
knew that it would not be long before
amanda announced that jeff had passed
through the final room
and would soon be headed to the
operation room with this came the
possibility that jeff would try to get
revenge on his captor so it was time for
jon to hide the tape that he had
previously recorded for detective
hoffman
since amanda's safety was also not
guaranteed he covered the tape in a
protective coat of candle wax and
swallowed it so that the medical
examiners could find it in his stomach
and forward it to detective hoffman
sometimes when people know that they're
gonna die they get their favorite food
as a final meal john gets to have an
audio tape covered in wax
so the less we eat the most lush fats we
get at ourselves
not long after amanda would come into
the room to deliver the message that
jeff had completed his final test
this meant that lynn had kept john alive
long enough to pass her test and he
orders amanda to let her go free
only amanda has other ideas the jeff
denlon trials as with the barn game the
bathroom game and the nerve gas house
game before it and when the pieces of
the puzzle the people involved with
those being tested come together
and as with the bathroom game this time
they all literally come together in the
same room
amanda's temper and jealousy had once
again gotten the better of her and she
refuses to let lynn go free after
passing her test
jon knows he can not directly say what
will happen if amanda kills lin but he
does give a warning that lin's life is
important because she controls the
outcome of amanda's life that ends up
making amanda even more upset
and jon tries to justify it by bringing
up the victims that amanda had murdered
how he had cleaned up her mistakes and
forgiven her but how he will not allow
her to go on as a murderer amanda argues
that lin could not have rehabilitated
because nobody that they had tested ever
really changed she proceeds to shoot
lynne denlon and when she does jeff is
there to see it
in retaliation jeff fires back and kills
amanda with lin dying on the floor
jigsaw has one final test for jeff
the lesson he had been trying to teach
throughout this entire endeavor was to
forgive
while jeff had shown signs of
forgiveness in each stage of his trial
he was unable to save any of the people
involved in the accident that resulted
in his son's death
now he would be faced with one more
decision to exact his revenge on the man
responsible for putting him and his wife
through even more hell or to let jigsaw
live in exchange for a chance to save
lin's life
after much deliberation jeff makes his
choice
i forgive you but in this case
forgiveness
is not enough even jon in the face of
death cannot help but smile
when jeff fires up the circular saw
blade i think the irony of this twist
was not lost on him
after all the people who he had made
suffer it would be one of his most
tortured test subjects who would reverse
that suffering back
onto him and with a circular spinning
sawblade no less the very same type of
weapon he had used upon his victims in
the very first portion of his first game
at the barn
it's almost like that baseball game i
brought up earlier where roldas chapman
gave up the alcs clenching home run and
all he can do is give this weird smile
because he knew that altuve waiting on
an off-speed pitch was no coincidence
with his very last bit of life jon rolls
jeff's tape
hello jeff i made this tape an
insurance policy if you will i
was your final test of forgiveness and
if you are listening to this
then you failed now you must pay the
price the tape reveals that jeff's other
child
corbett is locked away somewhere and
that only jon knows the location by
killing jigsaw jeff had essentially
locked the tomb of his own daughter
even if jon had lived there's no excuse
he could have made to his followers for
trapping an innocent young girl just to
punish jeff
so on the evening of april 28 2006
john's heart rate monitor flatlines and
the man feared by an entire city as the
jigsaw killer
is no more with his death lin's collar
goes off and jeff is locked inside the
operation room for life
after years of insistence that his
methods worked jon died
knowing that he had failed in early may
they would perform the autopsy on jon's
body and inside his stomach they found
not only john's cocoa puffs but also the
tape left for detective hoffman who
would continue to fill the shoes of
jigsaw until march of 2007.
john's body was buried in a local
cemetery where it would remain until the
year 2016 when his first disciple logan
nelson dug up his casket and switched
the body with that of edgar munson it is
unknown where kramer's body currently
resides
throughout this video we have discovered
the different puzzle pieces that make up
the life of john kramer
just as he played games with his victims
his own life in a way was a game where
each of these pieces came together to
form an icon
named jigsaw after a life of his own
agony he gave himself the power to judge
the lives of others
and as a result developed a dependence
on human suffering this caused him to
become a psychopath the likes of which
rival the greatest serial killers in all
of fiction he developed a god complex
and transformed his work from a series
of acts of violence into a movement a
religion with his own symbols
code of conduct and followers he claimed
to offer all of his subjects a second
chance at life but in reality he
destroyed the lives of over 50 people
some of which were bad criminals and
some of which were completely innocent
he was able to get as far as he did
based on two things that he did very
well the first was his engineering
degree he was a mechanical mastermind
making his traps perfect machines that
were only escapable in ways that he
intended the second was his ability to
anticipate the human mind he was a
master of game theory so every
conceivable possibility for each game
and really anything he did in life was
already thought out and had a solution
and what does that leave us with an
almost
finished puzzle because with all of
john's intellect and ability he was
never any better than any of the people
that he tested
jigsaw was missing a vital piece
[Music]
if you're a fan of saw click the
playlist on the left to see my horror
history analysis of other saw characters
and if you love horror make sure you
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
you